Let's begin with a discussion of the World Wide
Web. The World Wide Web is a collection of
HTML documents. These documents are made up of something
called HTML, which stands for HyperText Markup Language. This
is the basis for almost every webpage. Even though
there can be, you know, documents, images, videos, and
you know, all sorts of things online. HTML is
what glues everything together, and the links between these
pages called hyperlinks or links for short, is what makes the web, web-like.
The web was invented in the early 1990s, and has something on the order of
30 billion pages. Time for the first quiz. What is the main type of document on
the web? Is it HTML, Microsoft Word documents, PDFs, or Plain Text?